during the period 20 to 25 jun these
films were made of the activities of the
first brigade of the 100 first airborne
division incontinence as the 18 day long
operation hawthorne neared its end
aviation support elements undertook
civic action missions food and clothing
are delivered to friendly modern yard
settlements using helicopters for the
mag V sponsored project remote villages
of the mountain tribes men are visited
by American and Vietnamese
representatives sometimes called radhe
these Mountain dwellers build unique in
picturesque villages finally the chopper
arrives and slowly settles to a landing
the civic action team gets out and the
donated clothing and other supplies are
removed from the helicopter the modern
yards gather from all over the
settlement for the distribution of the
food and clothing for most of these
primitive people it is the first time
they have ever worn the garments of
Western man
the tribal chiefs new coveralls delight
him and he helps distribute the other
articles amongst his people but the
mission of this team does not end with
gifts of food and clothing a medical aid
group begins treatment for those who are
in need of attention the children are
taken first here in the remote mountain
communities there is no professional
medical care available and these people
look forward eagerly to the visits of
the American medics and their Vietnamese
assistance in a performance rarely seen
by outsiders girls of the village to a
traditional folk dance to entertain and
thank their visiting American friends
oriental gongs of several sizes and a
variety of tones are used to set the
rhythm for the dance from earliest
childhood these tribal daughters are
taught the ancient dances F docto on the
twenty-third of June a victory
celebration is held for the 100 first a
memorial honoring those who have fallen
in battle is flanked by an honor guard
of Arvind troops brigade commander
brigadier general Willard Pearson and
the commanding officer of the Arvin 41st
regiment lay wreaths at the monument the
ceremonies are hosted by the Arvin
regiment and the people of duct roll the
memorial ceremonies conclude with a
Vietnamese bugler blowing taps following
the ceremonies at the monument general
Pearson and his hosts go to inspect the
display of captured VC equipment being
exhibited in the center of town the
enemy's automatic weapons are a
particular interest to these Arvin
soldiers in a gesture symbolizing the
appreciation of the people of docto for
operation Hawthorne a selected group of
airborne troopers are presented with
flower garlands
then outside of town the battle-weary
veterans of operation Hawthorne come
marching in from the hills of
countenance their colors fly proudly as
they move wordlessly toward their black
area nearby as the dusty troopers passed
general Pearson and his staff their
commander salutes them in 18 days of
rugged mountain and jungle fighting
north of Dokdo these tough combat
veterans met and defeated the enemy in
repeated heavy contact enemy losses were
reported at 570 killed in action 22
captured pretty girls come out to offer
the returning men a cooling drink and
still they come returning to the
brigades forward base at the bivouac
area the men sit in front of their tents
and rest some check over equipment
operation Hawthorne is over and only
small chores occupy their attention
suddenly the word is passed movie actor
John Wayne is here Big John Wayne meets
I do I with Captain William F carpenter
upstanding soldier and former army
football star for the screaming eagles
the visit of Hollywood's heroic John
Wayne is an exciting event which not
even a driving rain is able to spoil but
their guests must soon depart and boards
his helicopter on the following day
general Pearson addresses the troops he
congratulates them for a job well done
and breached them on the next operation
afterwards unit commanders go over
details the new operation will be known
as Operation Eagle bait and involves
both troopers of the 100 first and
Vietnamese Hill regulars in their
camouflage outfits the troopers receive
last minute
instructions for some there are
lingering thoughts of experiences on
previous operations then the time for
thinking is over and the combined troops
moved to the nearby Dokdo airstrip and
prepare for airlift into enemy control
territory the Viet Cong are to be given
no time for recovery from the impact of
operation Hawthorne
the flake ooh flight operations center
provides important air traffic control
for the strategic Central Highlands
region of South Vietnam the center is
located at the US Army Airfield camp
Holloway it's assignment to monitor all
army flights including reconnaissance
air supply and troop-carrying missions
inside the flight operations van radio
communications connect aircraft with the
airfield control elements the
coordination control section of the van
is equipped with facilities for
following flight patterns flight data is
recorded on plotting boards which chart
the location of aircraft in the area
tower personnel observed traffic coming
through the field and Lord all flights
wind direction and other flight
information is relayed to aircraft for
aid in takeoff and landing teletype
equipment in the van sends vital flight
information to other air control
stations and to control headquarters at
Thomson of Air Base the camp Holloway
tower provides 24-hour a day traffic
control and handles hundreds of army
flights daily including rotary and
fixed-wing aircraft
on 25 jun at Cam Ranh Bay a company of
army engineers is assigned to
construction and repair of pier
facilities divers trained at Army and
Navy diving schools prepare for the
operation this unit is equipped for all
types of underwater construction the
gear worn by the divers is for use in
shallow water
air hoses to the divers are fed from
large tanks which are laid out on the
pier
the cross beams on this fuel jetty have
rotted through and new beams have to be
installed divers from the unit have
recently completed LST docking
facilities and help build an underwater
retaining wall at adda long pier site
construction of the United States Army
worldwide communications facilities
continued to move forward in May and
June in Southeast Asia on the northeast
coast at the non Vietnamese women dig
foundation trenches for the integrated
wideband communication system
installation this system which primarily
utilizes tropospheric scatter for radio
wave propagation provides consistent
signals over long distances Philippine
workers also are employed on the job
here seen connecting power cables to a
power generator van and aligning a
reflector des farther south at Metron is
another I WCS site antenna locations are
surveyed accurately to aim the giant
dishes toward other relay stations along
the route tons of steel I beams are
unloaded for use in the construction
wooden forms are erected for foundations
of microwave antennas play ku is another
link in the communications network steel
rods are assembled in sections to use in
reinforcing the concrete structures here
is a portion of the concrete base for a
120-foot antenna a guard tower is being
built for use in providing security for
the installation
at the site at fool um fuel tanks are
being readied for operation these large
tanks will hold the fuel necessary to
operate the generators which will supply
electric power to the system at Vung Tau
where considerable progress has already
been made large quantities of Steel
await assembly at the communication site
this excavation is for the emplacement
of an MRC 85 signal van when these
facilities are completed United States
military forces will be assured of
dependable communications in the area
before dawn on 28 jun a convoy moves out
of camp coleman near santo domingo in
the dominican republic after seven
months as a part of the inter-american
police force the 320th artillery 82nd
Airborne Division is going home enroute
to Red Beach it's embarkation point the
convoy crosses the Duarte bridge which
the rebels have barricaded during the
height of the fighting it passes shell
riddled buildings mute reminders of the
battles which had raged here only months
ago then a wait at the ocean's edge on
schedule an LST the Waldo County arrives
to take on this contingent of the 320th
for return to sunny Point North Carolina
other elements of the unit are returning
by air with the election of Juan de
llegar as president of the Dominican
Republic the Organization of American
States has voted to disband the
inter-american police force the 320th is
the first unit to leave the boarding
begins each freshly-painted vehicle
moves into line in a carefully
coordinated sequence then is directed to
its position within the LST
when the equipment is aboard the troops
move on to the ship and up to the deck
where they take places along the rail as
the LST prepares to leave the men are
thanked for their service by Brazilian
general Alvaro Baja commander in chief
of the inter-american police force then
the Waldo County gets underway on the
four day trip back home while the first
convoy is moving out to see another
section of the 320th arrives at San
Ysidro Airport in brief ceremonies
Brigadier General Robert Linville
commanding general US forces Dominican
Republic commends the troops then the
men moved to their waiting c-130s
farewells are said as the planes are
boarded equipment and luggage are loaded
for the 320th airborne artillery it's
goodbye Dominican Republic hello home
on 27 jun in bong pong thailand the thai
prime minister inspects an honor guard
the occasion is the dedication of a new
processing plant built by the preserved
food organization among those greeting
the prime minister is the senior US Army
logistical advisor to the royal thai
army colonel thomas g frost a Buddhist
altar has been set up on the grounds and
the Prime Minister opens the ceremonies
by lighting a candle and briefly praying
for the success of the new factory it
will turn out preserved foods for the
Royal Thai Armed Forces police and other
government agencies the director of the
processed food organization introduces
the prime minister who briefly addresses
the audience of Thai government
officials and members of the diplomatic
corps then as balloons source skyward to
celebrate the occasion the plant is
dedicated and the Prime Minister begins
a tour of the facility
this factory is fully equipped and a
modern installation in every respect the
United States government has followed
its planning and construction closely
the plant will employ approximately 500
persons when for production capacity is
achieved it represents a significant
addition to the Thai economic structure
every year the citizens of petal Brooke
Luxembourg observe Remembrance Day to
honor the memory of lieutenant general
george s patton jr. it was from this
city that General Patton commanding the
United States 3rd army launched his
counterattack in the battle of the bulge
on December 16 1944 jun 25th the day
preceding remembrance day begins with
sports events including skydiving by men
of both the 8th Infantry Division and
supreme headquarters Allied powers in
Europe guests include mrs. Patricia
Roberts Harris the US ambassador to
Luxembourg and Lieutenant General
Theodore J Conway commanding general of
a 7th army thousands of people come out
in the rain to see the parade and the
ceremonies troop units and military
bands from seven nations parade down
Avenue John F Kennedy
ambassador Harris here delivers a
memorial address then mrs. Harris and
the mayor of ever Brooke assisted by the
mayor's two sons lay wreaths at the base
of a patent monument